[Music]
both heartache and relief in Alberta on
this Monday night good to be back yeah
the thousands were turning home the
fight to douse the Flames still posing a
threat what's in the forecast and the
request for military reinforcements
persona non grata Canada expels the
Chinese Diplomat accused of intimidating
a Tory MP and his family we will not
tolerate any form of foreign
interference
Russia's new bombardments in Ukraine and
moscow's fears ahead of Soviet Victory
Day
plus succession Prince William's
preparations and strategies before he
eventually becomes king
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Fara Nasser good
evening to you and thank you for joining
us we begin in Alberta where wildfires
have forced nearly 30 000 people from
their homes the military will help with
securing evacuation zones with
transporting supplies and Performing
manual labor but it's not clear when the
deployment will start Premier Danielle
Smith says financial assistance will be
offered to displace families eligible
adults could receive more than twelve
hundred dollars
this means that an evacuated family of
four will receive thirty five hundred
dollars to help get through these dark
days and to meet their immediate needs
these payments will help evacuees pay
for accommodations food and other basic
necessities
across the province there are close to a
hundred active wildfires cooler
temperatures and some rain has helped
but more hot dry weather is forecast
while some evacuees were able to return
home today that wasn't the case
everywhere like here in Yellowhead
County one of the communities devastated
by the fires its mayor estimates that 25
homes have been lost and we have Team
coverage across the province for you but
we're going to begin with Heather urac's
West who's in the town of Edson Heather
pharah this has truly been an emotional
day in this part of the province relief
and joy for many in this tight-knit
community but also anguish for families
who have lost everything just a short
distance away
after a tense and uncertain few days the
people of Edson are coming home home
sweet home a bit of rain went a long way
for this Alberta community on Monday
morning the evacuation order for the
town and areas of north and west
Yellowhead County was lifted
ah good to be back yeah it's nice we
needed the rain it's a slow return to
normal and people are gonna be happy to
be home I guess protecting the community
of Edson was a priority in the
province's fire fight outside of town
rural residents weren't so lucky
Northeast of Edson the fire consumed
several buildings including Gabriel
betcher's home we tried to save the farm
we with the water truck so we tried to
basically put lots of water around it
but I guess
the wind picked up and we just actually
couldn't do much about it Gabriel better
had been away visiting relatives at the
time now returning to this devastating
scene they're basically on the way home
and I guess start all over again even
during all this Devastation there are
small miracles as well when the fire
crossed the highway on the weekend it
destroyed the structures and trees on
this property but somehow the home was
spared the mayor of Yellowhead County
estimates as many as 25 homes have been
lost in the region and the threat in
some areas is still too dangerous for
residents to return and check in on
their homes but in exit for now the
immediate danger has passed and
community members are taking the time to
feel thankful and relieved welcome back
everybody and everybody be safe
the question lingering on many Minds
here is for how long will the threat of
fire return especially with scorching
temperatures in the forecast in just a
few days Farah
Heather York's West and Edson Alberta
thank you heather we're going to get to
that forecast in just a little bit but
another dangerous fire is burning out of
control and it's bearing down on Drayton
Valley which is about 90 minutes west of
Edmonton thousands of residents have
left as about 300 firefighters work to
protect the town and that's where Joel
senec is tonight Joel you heard from the
fire chief a short time ago so what did
he have to say
far the fire chief says this is still an
extremely dangerous situation and the
Wildfire remains out of control an
evacuation order remains in place it was
given late Thursday night people have
been out of this town since then and
today officials took media on a tour
just south of the town that is where a
major area of concern remains tonight
you can see where fire ripped through
the area but looks may be deceiving it
may appear this is extinguished
officials say that's not the case there
are hot spots that could flare up trees
that can still burn in this region and
if the wind changes it could be a
problem and that is why the roughly 7
000 people who call Drayton Valley Home
cannot return the fire chief says he's
receiving immense pressure from
residents to reopen the town and tonight
he's pleading for people to understand
we are getting immense pressure from our
evacuees to come back to the community
and they want to come home
we hear you I have a family too
that's not here
now the Big Hope here in Drayton Valley
is that the weather cooperates we have
seen rain over the past two days
officials say it has helped fight this
fire but far unfortunately it is not
enough to lift the mandatory evacuation
order
Joel senec and Drayton Valley Alberta
what a challenge there thank you so as
you just heard Alberta has seen a mixed
bag of weather let's bring in Global
News meteorologist Tiffany lisay with
what's in store next Tiffany
Farah cooler temperatures and scattered
showers have certainly helped the
Wildfire situation across the province
you'll notice a low fire risk for much
of Central and Southern Alberta now
whereas Northern Alberta still sits
between a high and extreme fire risk now
across the province throughout today
tomorrow and Wednesday we're going to
see some scattered showers as well as
some isolated thunderstorms we want the
rain we don't want lightning that could
spark up more wildfires so we're
watching that but the other issue is
these scattered showers are fairly
isolated not necessarily bringing
moisture to the areas that need it here
is showing where some of those wildfires
are looking ahead at Thursday that's
when we'll see another Ridge of high
pressure re-establish itself very
similar to last week and we'll see it
sandwiched between two low pressure
systems forming another Omega block and
that's going to set the Prairies up for
another stretch of hot dry weather with
temperatures into the high 20 20s and
low 30s not reassuring news for those
already impacted by what's been a very
active start to our Wildfire season
Farah
Global News meteorologist Tiffany lisay
thank you for that Tiffany
now to another developing story tonight
this one in Ottawa the latest on
allegations of foreign interference the
liberal government's expelling a Chinese
Diplomat accused if intimidating a
conservative MP and his family in Hong
Kong Mackenzie gray joins us now from
Ottawa McKenzie first how did this all
unfold yeah far after months of pressure
on the Chinese interference the Liberals
have made their biggest definitive
action yet the government of Canada has
declared the individual in question
today a diplomat from China Mr Xiao Wei
persona non grata
is the Chinese Diplomat of the center of
a plan outlining at 2021 thesis report
to Target conservative MP Michael Chong
and his family after Chong's supported
emotion condemning beijing's treatment
of the uyghur minority we will not
tolerate any form of foreign
interference in our Internal Affairs the
Minister of Foreign Affairs has taken
this decision carefully after
considering all factors but reaching
that decision took the government a week
after the Chong story was first reported
in the Globe and Mail now the Prime
Minister who says he wasn't briefed on
the seizes report said he was concerned
about all the potential impacts and
dispulsion could have on canada-china
relations but Chong believes the
government should have taken action
sooner
this decision to expel a diplomat should
have been should have taken place years
ago the fact is we've become somewhat of
a playground for foreign interference
threat activities
the diplomats expulsion was announced in
the middle of a House of Commons vote
brought forward by the conservatives are
calling on the government to remove the
Diplomat but also to call for a public
Inquirer on the issue establishing a
foreign agents registry and also closing
down Chinese police stations in Canada
and that non-binding motion past the
House of Commons but the Liberals voted
against it so it's inexplicable by the
government is refusing to support
emotion calling on the adoption of three
other measures to help protect Canadians
here on Canadian soil
the Chinese Embassy responded to the
expulsions saying they'll take
countermeasures against Canada Farah for
sending one of their top diplomats home
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie the federal government is
renewing a multi-million dollar program
to fight gun crime and gang violence the
public safety Minister says 390 million
dollars is being invested over five
years
these federal funds will be distributed
to the provinces and territories for the
purpose of giving law enforcement the
additional people resources and supports
that they need to get the job done and
to get the job done safely
the federal government is also looking
to introduce new changes to the bail
system to address violent repeat
offenders especially those involved in
weapons related crimes firearm related
homicides have been steadily increasing
in Canada and gang-related homicides
involving guns have nearly doubled since
2013.
earlier this year Canada was left out of
a military deal between three of our
major allies the U.S the UK and
Australia they signed the August
agreement aiming to boost Security in
the indo-pacific region now there are
signs
Ottawa wants to join the club too but it
comes at a time when some allies are
losing patience and trust with Canada's
contributions Sharia Israeli reports
when August was first announced
noticeably absent
the U.S UK and Australia signed on to a
military pact to deepen cooperation in
the indo-pacific and counter China's
Rising power at first the liberal
government brushed off being left out
good morning everybody but now as first
reported by the globe and mail it wants
in defense minister Anita Anand would
not confirm the reports but signaled she
wants closer ties with August members we
are highly interested in continuing to
work with our allies there's no
guarantee International Partners will
welcome Canada into the fold our allies
don't have a lot of enthusiasm for us
simply looking to join yet another club
they do have an interest in seeing what
Canada might be interested in
contributing Canada's military spending
routinely lags behind its Partners last
month The Washington Post reported prime
minister Justin Trudeau admitted
privately Canada will never achieve NATO
targets despite publicly promising to
meet them there are also no plans to
Place Canada's aging submarine Fleet
even as adversaries send their subs into
the Arctic the rise of China as a global
power is is of concern and of course we
can't ignore Russia military experts
believe there are ways Canada can
contribute to August like anti-submarine
Warfare and underwater research but it's
not clear if they will be enough to
convince the U.S the UK and Australia to
let Canada into the club
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
Russia unleashes a new wave of missile
strikes on Ukraine coming up the attacks
on the eve of Soviet Victory Day
at least five people had been injured in
the Ukrainian Capital after a series of
Russian airstrikes the mayor of Kiev
called it one of the biggest Kamikaze
drone attacks in the war so far several
cities were targeted just 24 hours
before Russia marks Victory Day to
celebrate the defeat of Nazi Germany
holiday preparations are underway but
moscow's announced a major security
clamp down including a ban on the use of
drones car sharing and even jet skis as
Crystal gomancing Reports both sides
appear to be on high alert
this Warehouse destroyed early Monday in
a Russian airstrike on Odessa all of the
humanitarian Aid inside the 1 000 square
meter building gone to the Red Cross
says no workers were inside the facility
at the time but given the destruction
some projects in the area have been
suspended a series of Russian strikes
rained down on several regions including
Odessa harkiv mikalayev her son and Kiev
at one point Monday the entire country
was blanketed by an attack Alert warning
I heard a loud explosions as this 76
year old woman when asked what she did
she replied there was nothing I could do
I sheltered in the corridor behind two
walls Vitale Klitschko says Russia sent
36 Kamikaze drones to the capital but
all were destroyed by the air defense
system five people was taking the
injuries to people right now in
hospitals but nobody has died it's very
important the attacks come as Ukraine
and Europe celebrate victory over Nazi
Germany in the end of the second world
war in Russia Victory celebrations
happen on May 9th the Kremlin had been
pushing for success in the East to
highlight during their festivities last
year ukrainians were told to take Extra
Care on the 8th and 9th fearing an
onslaught of attacks from Russia this
year A reversal of rolls several Russian
cities have canceled or scaled back
Soviet Victory Day saying they could be
targeted by pro-ukrainian saboteurps
it's unclear if that is the result of an
explosion last week at the Kremlin which
Moscow claims was a Ukrainian attempt on
the president's life or because so many
Russian soldiers have been killed and
weapons destroyed that a big military
parade just as impossible this year
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Mall Massacre ahead the Texas Community
mourning another mass shooting
[Music]
Texans are mourning another violent
tragedy on Saturday gunman went on a
rampage in a mall in Allen a suburb of
Dallas killing eight people and it's the
state's second mass shooting in barely
over a week
it's the second deadliest shooting in
the United States this year after the
January shooting at a dance studio near
Los Angeles just five months into 2023
there have been more than 200 mass
shootings that's more than one per day
Jackson prosco has the Grim new info
coming out of this latest violence and a
warning to you the details are
disturbing
[Music]
in Allen Texas Sunday they gathered to
mourn we're going to need prayer
so please
think about our families here in this
community this community is still trying
to make sense of the senseless after a
mass shooting that killed and injured so
many
four of the victims were from a single
family three-year-old James Cho was
killed along with his parents Cindy and
Q six-year-old William was injured but
survived it was scary I mean anybody
would be scaring to hear gunshots Nicks
don't know what's going on
the shooting happened at an outlet mall
Saturday when police say 33-year-old
Mauricio Garcia opened fire with a
high-powered assault rifle the gunman
was killed by a police officer who
happened to be at the mall and ran
toward the gunshots I never imagined in
a hundred years I would be thrust into
the position of being the first first
responder on the site to take care of
people no one can see what they saw
today and not be affected by it reports
suggest the gunman wore a patch linked
to far-right extremists and shared white
supremacist beliefs online
there have been over 200 mass shootings
in the U.S this year yet Texas continues
to loosen its gun laws the governor
insists the problem is mental health not
guns there has been a dramatic increase
in the amount of anger and violence
that's taking place in America in
Washington U.S President Joe Biden
continues to press lawmakers to pass an
assault weapons ban we are talking about
the number one killer of kids in America
and republicans in Congress are saying
there is nothing that we can do about it
yet there is little political will to
stop the next mass shooting from
happening continuing the epidemic of
violence that has shattered so many
lives
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
Heir Apparent how Prince William's life
life changed as the next in line
[Music]
people across the UK closed out king
Charles's coronation Celebrations by
giving back to their communities today
in an event called the big help out
Prince William and his family also took
part and there's definitely more
attention to what he'll do next he's
next in line for the throne and he will
inherit it sooner than his father did
Eric Sorensen looks at what may be in
store with this Future King
it's no accident that Prince William's
first post-coronation event dispensed
with the pageantry and showed the whole
family helping out a scout troop Prince
Louis moving dirt princess Charlotte
painting frames and George the next in
line to the throne handling a power tool
assigned to all that this is a working
family royalty with a common touch but
still royalty I William Prince of Wales
pledge my loyalty to you William like
his father has been groomed for these
occasions instilled since childhood with
the same sense of purpose to be a future
king yet he is better prepared than was
his father for the modern mass media
ready to engage with the public as his
mother Princess Diana was able to do a
balance of informality with propriety we
have in William a future king that has
that traditional conservative Royal Duty
side to him but because of his mother as
well he's also got that accessible
personal personable sighting
[Music]
William and Catherine have steered clear
of the marital Scandal that plagued his
parents though he will face public
criticism over the damaged relationship
with his brother Harry and wife Megan
William Will Embrace advocacy in ways
that his father as king no longer can
he's already taken on a cause the royal
family never considered mental health
supporting the mental health of our
Emergency Services is extremely personal
to me William's ability to reach out
will be tested a modern royal family
trying to remain relevant among
Commonwealth Nations and Indigenous
people who feel less and less connected
to the British Monarchy this is their
chance to show a degree of sympathy and
empathy with
dispossessed post-colonial populations
that could be really useful in
strengthening ties with the monarchy
William like his dad will spend most of
his life laying the groundwork for his
future role as Monarch embodying the
particular sense of Duty that falls to
the era parent at the heart of the
pageantry is a simple message
service for William service to the
public and to the king Paul we are all
so proud of you and until it is his time
William and his family will try to make
a good impression
Eric Sorensen Global News
and that's global national for this
Monday night I'm foreign osser and for
tonight's your Canada we honor these two
Canadians Carolina visioneska and Josh
Vander Vice today they were announced as
Team Canada's co-chefste mission for the
2023 parapan m games and the 2024
Paralympics Carolina is a former para
Alpine skier and Josh is a former Bacha
player it is the first time the chefs de
Mission rule has been shared the duo
will share their expertise support and
guide athletes and be Team Canada's
biggest cheerleaders thank you for
watching good night
[Music]